(fast shamisen music)
- [Narrator] The shamisen
is one of Japan's
traditional musical instruments.
Among its performers,
the Yoshida brothers are
known to play a quick tempo.
Lightening quick.
(audicence clapping)
(shamisen music)
The Yoshida brothers are
masters of the shamisen,
a classic Japanese guitar famous for being
the accompanying music in
Japanese kabuki theater.
But the shamisen has various genres
and has evolved from an ancient past.
The brothers began learning the shamisen
at just 5 years old.
As they progressed,
they fell in love with the
genre of tsugaru-shamisen,
which is over 150 years old
and has a very quick tempo.
The brothers have revitalized the shamisen
for audiences today by
melding new modern sounds
with the ancient art.
And in doing so,
they've gained popularity worldwide.
(audience clapping)
They perform to sold-out concert
halls throughout the year
in the hopes of spreading
their love for their craft.
But the intensity of their playing
takes a toll on their bodies.
(audience clapping)